>> From the Library Of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Michelle Cadoree Bradley:
I'm Michelle Cadoree Bradley,
a research specialist in the Science
Technology and Business division
of the Library of Congress,
and I'd like to welcome
you to today's program.
Walking With the Last
Men on the Moon.
Revisiting the Apollo
17 landing site,
with the Lunar Reconnaissance
Orbiter.
Tomorrow, December 7th, is the 44th
anniversary of the Apollo 17 launch.
The last manned mission to the moon.
Today, we will revisit the
landing site with our guide
from NASA, Dr. Noah Petro.
He is a lunar geologist and
the deputy project scientist
for the Lunar Reconnaissance
Orbiter, which launched in 2009.
Dr. Petro became interested
in geology in high school.
He has received a BS in
geology from Bates College
where he was introduced to the
field of planetary geology.
He has a PhD in geological
sciences from Brown
and was a NASA Post Doc before
becoming a research scientist there
in 2009.
I also understand that he has
a familial history with NASA,
which perhaps he will go into,
but if not, I encourage you
to review his NASA
scientist interview
which is available
from the NASA website.
Please help me welcome Noah
Petro to the Library of Congress.
[applause]
>> Noah Petro: Wow.
Alright, well thank you very much
for that awesome introduction.
I'm really quite humbled to be here
today to talk to you about something
that I care deeply about.
As mentioned, space
exploration is sort of in my DNA.
My father, when he
graduated from college
in the early 1960's
immediately took a job working
for a contractor working for NASA
building parts for the Lunar Module
and for the backpack that the
astronauts wore when they were
on the surface of the moon.
So for instance, in this picture
here of Jack Schmidt standing
on the Apollo 17 landing site,
my dad built parts for
the backpack there.
And actually, as a kid, that really
didn't resonate with me too much.
I don't think most kids
really care all that much
about what their parents do, as
long as they're there to take them
to baseball games or whatever it is.
But we were at a museum, The Cradle
of Aviation Museum in Long Island
and he started, he never really
made a big deal about it,
we go to the air and space museum as
a kid of course and that was awesome
and we talked about Apollo.
And hey, kid, people
went to the moon.
And things like that.
But then at the museum, he
said, oh you see this piece?
This was part of the backpack
and I helped build that.
Wow! And you know, one
of the things that we did
and nobody knows this, he told me.
And he pulled me aside and said,
see that piece of metal that sort
of holds the whole thing together,
it doesn't really do anything
except hold the backpack together,
the guts of the backpack together?
Well, all of the engineers, when
we were finished building one,
we take out the etcher, the metal
etcher, and sign our names on it.
So at some point in the future,
although we know that each
of the Apollo landing sites
are preserved or intended
to be preserved, if someone
were to go and crack open one
of the twelve backpacks that are
left on the surface of the moon,
there will be the scribble
that if you could decipher it,
it would say Dennis Petro.
So it is a proud heritage
of studying the moon
and revisiting some of the
work that he did in the 1960's
to help get the astronauts
to the moon.
If you've ever seen the Apollo 13
movie, there's the famous scene
where the astronauts are trying
to take the round connector
and put it in the square hole.
He built the round
oxygen exchange canister
that was in the lunar module.
So it's with a lot of gratitude
that I come to talk about Apollo 17.
As mentioned, tomorrow
morning, the wee hours of 12:33
in the morning will be
the anniversary of launch
and really start the celebrations,
as limited as they may be,
for the 45th anniversary
of the Apollo 17 landing
which will occur next year.
Before I get started, though,
I want to take a moment to talk
about why I care about or why
I think I care about the moon.
I got a colleague of mine, Jim
Zimmlin, who works at the Air
and Space Museum and the Center
of Earth and Planetary Studies,
if you were to ask him this
question he would have a different
answer perhaps.
So this reflects my thinking on
why we think the moon is important.
And I'm talking about
my home team here.
I was vested interest in the moon,
obviously, but I think of the moon
of the cornerstone of
understanding how planets work.
We can learn about a lot
by studying the Earth.
That's why we go out and
study lava flows in Hawaii.
How do planets work?
But the Earth is not the
best example of a planet.
We have our lovely atmosphere, we've
got water that erodes the surface.
If you look at the other planets,
large objects in our solar system,
outside on the table outside in
the hall, I encourage you to pick
up the information about the
new Verizon's mission which flew
by Pluto several months back.
Those images of Pluto reveal a
world that's unlike anything,
at least I expected.
But our understanding of the moon is
what helps us interpret the record
of the surface of Pluto, of Mercury,
ultimately of any object
in the solar system.
My mind goes back to
understanding what's going
on on the lunar surface.
Because the moon is
close to the Earth,
it took the astronauts
three days to get there.
It is a neighbor.
I like to think of the moon
as sort of the Earth's attic.
It's where the ancient record
of the inter-solar system,
our corner of the solar
system, is recorded.
In the rocks on the
surface of the moon.
And because we have the
six Apollo landing sites,
we have those successful missions
that brought rocks
back to the Earth.
Those samples tell us
something very important
about how the moon evolved, and by
association we can use those rocks
to understand how the moon evolved
and how planets work in general.
But one of the things that we get
from our mission that's
orbiting the moon right now,
The Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter,
is the context for those samples.
A rock is a wonderful thing,
but a rock with context
where you know exactly where it
came from, where it's history is
that you can use to tell a story,
tells a lot about how
a planet works.
And so what I'm going to
talk about in the latter half
of my presentation, is the
context of some samples
that we got form Apollo 17
and how the new data we have helps
us better understand what those
rocks are telling us.
We're here and building
a facility that's devoted
to the history of the written word.
The rocks, I like to think of
rocks as kind of like little books.
It's up to us to understand
what those books are telling us.
A rock without context is like one
of the middle books of a volume.
If you took book three
of Harry Potter,
well you don't know what
went on on either sides.
But if you have context, the
full volume of an encyclopedia
or Harry Potter, you get a
better sense of the whole story.
And so when we get the
context of these samples,
whether it's through the images
the Apollo astronauts took
or those images in the context of
the entire planet and the globe
of the moon, that tells us
something very important
about how the moon works.
So that's my preamble about why
I think the moon is important.
Hopefully, if you're
convinced, that's wonderful.
If not, well let's at least enjoy
talking about some of the things
that I do on a daily basis.
This is one of those awesome
external rocket camera footage
that we get from rocket launches.
This was in the late
afternoon of June 18th, 2009.
The launch of the Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter.
This is in the pre
hi-def day, by the way.
I sort of shutter to show this.
But it is still pretty
spectacular, the launch of LRO.
Now, LRO has been at the
moon for over seven years.
That feels like it's gone
by pretty quickly to me.
But the seven years that LRO has
been at the moon is important,
and not just because that's seven
years of funding for someone
like me to work on the mission.
But it's seven years of
studying the moon in a way
that we've never been
able to do before.
Oftentimes, what we do in planetary
science is we go to a new object,
we go to Mars, we either fly by
it as we did in the case of Pluto
or we orbit it very shortly.
What's happened at Mars with our
long duration of orbital missions
and indeed now what's
happening at the moon,
is we're not measuring the moon
in ways we've never
been able to do before.
We're actually able to
[inaudible] the changes that occur
on the surface of the moon.
We're finding new impact craters
that have formed in
the last seven years.
Now if you're like me, first
of all I apologize for that,
but if you're like me you go to
Google Earth and maybe you look
at your neighborhood, and
you use the little slider
to see what your neighborhood looked
like ten years ago,
twenty years ago.
We can do that for
areas of the moon now.
We can see images from eight years
ago, not eight, six years ago,
and images taken yesterday
and compare them
and actually see changes
that are occurring
on the surface of the moon.
Why is that important?
Well, before LRO we
had no idea the rate
at which the surface
of the moon changed.
And as I said before,
our understanding
of the moon is what we use
to leverage our understanding
of all other objects
in the solar system.
So when we learn that
the moon is dynamic,
it's changing at a very slow
rate but still changing,
that tells us something important
about what's happening on asteroids,
Mercury, throughout
the solar system.
Indeed, one of the most
interesting implications relevant
to the Apollo landing sites
is those beautiful footprints.
We're all familiar with
the image from Apollo 11
of Buzz Aldrin's boot print.
And the thought for years was
that that boot print would be
visible for millions of years.
It turns out that the rate
of change, the new impacts
and the turning of the surface of
the moon is happening much faster
than we expected and that boot
print may disappear in the scale
of 100,000 years, not
a million years.
Now that may not seem all
that important but again,
we are using the moon as a natural
laboratory to understand the process
that are affecting
all of the planets
in the solar system,
including the Earth.
So LRO, and I'm going to
show a lot of pictures today.
Because pictures are
worth 1,000 words
but LRO has many, many instruments.
Seven instruments, in fact.
When LRO was launched in
2009, there was a plan
that we would eventually
send humans and robots back
to the surface of the moon.
And so we wanted a
Reconnaissance mission.
A mission that would find the safe
and interesting landing sites.
That would tell us where to go and
how to stay at the moon safely.
And so these instruments were
selected to find safe places
to basically pave the way for
human exploration into deep space.
They're also selected
to help us find places
where you might find water
or [inaudible] at the moon.
One of the objectives was
originally to send humans
to the moon to live off the land.
And one of the ways to do that
is to not have to bring all
of the water and oxygen with you.
So we wanted to find places
where we could get water
from the lunar surface.
And so we have instruments
ranging from a radiation detector
that measures how much radiation
damage a human might expect
when they're traveling to the moon.
We have a thermal instrument that
measures the surface temperature
of the moon, an instrument that will
measure reflected starlight that's
light not form our sun, but
light from all the other stars
in the galaxy that reflect
off the nice side off the moon
to suggest where water might be.
We have a neutron detector that can
map out where hydrogen is present,
commonly in the form
of oxygen or OOH.
We have a laser instrument that
measures the surface topography
of the moon with a precision
greater than any object
that we have in the solar system.
We have the best topography, not
to sound like a future President.
We have the best Topography
in the solar system
at the moon thanks to
the Lola instrument.
The L Rock instrument, a camera
which is actually 3 different
cameras, has mapped the moon
at resolutions of approximately
fifty centimeters per pixel.
We're going to see a lot
of those pictures today.
And a radar instrument that allows
us to peer beneath the surface.
Kind of 3D glasses, x-ray
glasses to see what's going
on in the first upper
meter or so of the surface.
That gives us a sense of what's
happening to the lunar surface.
Also, it's been used
to map out the presence
of ice deposits near
the lunar poles.
So all of these instruments combined
gibe us this really incredible view
of the moon that we've
never had before.
Because we've been to the moon,
we went with the Apollo mission six
times, several times to lunar orbit
with Apollo, we have
a misguided sense
that we know everything
about the moon.
And I think one of the things that
we're learning from LRO is a lot
of our presumptions about
the moon have been wrong,
or if nothing else, incorrect.
Now just a few other moments of
promotion, I encourage everyone
if you haven't gone to the second
floor of the Air and Space Museum,
there's an exhibit devoted to
the results coming back from LRO,
particularly from the camera.
This is Mt. Marilyn and
again for those of you
who remember the Apollo 13 movie,
Jim Lovell who had orbited the
moon previously on Apollo 8,
named this mountain after his wife.
So sometimes in the movie you'll
hear him talking about it.
This is an LROC image again high
resolution, oblique out of the,
I think of it as the window view
although we don't actually have
windows on the spacecraft, we
tilt the spacecraft to the side
to get an image like this.
But there's an entire
gallery devoted to images
from the LROC instrument.
The gallery will be open at least
through the end of this year,
so you have at least one
more month but I've been told
that it's likely going to be there
into the early part of next year
until they find something
to replace it.
It's definitely worth the visit.
I would normally say
it's on the side
where the lunar module
was but that doesn't help.
It's like getting directions
from someone in Maine.
You go to where that
place used to be.
It's on the McDonald's side
of the-- everybody knows that.
It's on the McDonald's
side of the museum.
The second floor.
A few other just upcoming
events that we want
to make sure everyone is aware of.
On August 21st, there will
be a total solar eclipse.
The path of totality
crisscrosses the country going
from Oregon all the way
across through South
Carolina and out to sea.
Even in D.C., we'll get a really
nice show of partially obscured sun
but we want to remind everyone
that the central player
in a solar eclipse is the moon.
And again, because we have a
very accurate representation,
we have an accurate dataset
of the topography of the moon,
we can actually predict with a
really high degree of accuracy,
the exact shape and path
of that eclipse that goes
across the central part
of the United States.
In fact, we have an understanding
of the topography of the moon
to such a degree that the
uncertainty is down to
about a second or so of the
timing of the eclipse are not due
to any uncertainty of the
shape of the Earth or the moon,
it's actually uncertainty
to the shape of the sun.
So basically, we can blame all
of our friends in helio-physics
for not standing up and getting
enough information to us.
So that should be a really
great event next summer.
October 28th of next year
also is another event
that the LRO mission
supports and that's going
to be International
Observe the Moon night.
If you go to observethemoonnight.org
you can learn more about that
but there are events all across the
world actually where we get people
out looking through
telescopes and thinking
and learning about the moon.
Ok, so Apollo 17 and 44 years later.
So I would highly recommend
that everyone wake up,
when you turn your phone back off
of sleep mode, wake up at 12:33,
go to the website, a
friend of mine Ben Feist
who is here today created
Apollo17.org
and at 12:33 the mission
will play out in real time
over the next ten days or
so, as the mission unravels.
And it's a shameless plug.
There's no money gained from it,
it's just for the sake of knowledge.
But Apollo 17, they saved
the best for last ultimately.
It was the first night launch of
the Apollo mission was viewed up
and down the East coast
and really was the climax
of the entire space
program up to that point.
You had the Mercury, Gemini, and
the preceding Apollo missions all
in my mind building
up to this moment,
where we could get astronauts to
go to the moon, live on the moon
for three days, work, drive a car,
commute, no traffic not like here.
But it also represents the last time
that humans traveled
into deep space.
The astronauts were very fortunate.
In August of 1972, some months
before a large solar flare passed
through the sun, passed
through the Earth moon system.
Had astronauts been on
the moon at that time,
there could have been potentially
serious medical effects to them.
They dodged a solar
bullet, as it were.
There are hazards to exploring deep
space and they were very fortunate.
All of the Apollo astronauts were
very fortunate to make the roundtrip
as President Kennedy outlined.
So for a little context of
what lunar expiration is like,
this is a map put together
by the camera team.
Normally I like to
wander towards the screen.
I like to gravitate
towards the moon.
I'm going to try to stay close to
the microphones for a moment here.
This is the hemisphere of the moon
that we're most familiar looking at.
And actually, the image of the moon
here you see is stitched together
with hundreds of smaller images
to make this beautiful map
of the moon showing the relief of
the moon, the texture of the moon.
Now in grain and barely visible here
are all of the Apollo landing sites.
Apollo 17 is here, Apollo
11 landed to the South,
12 and 14, 15, 16, 17 now.
Just as a reminder,
there's an entire half
of the moon that's not shown here.
An entire hemisphere that has
never been explored on the surface.
And as I very gingerly lean over
out in front here is a lithograph
of both the near and far side.
I would encourage everyone
to grab a copy.
I say that because there
is a whole half of the moon
that has not been explored.
The surface area of the moon
is roughly the size of Africa.
If I were to tell you that we've
been, I've been to Africa six times
and I've seen everything, I've
learned everything there is to learn
about Africa, I'd be
laughed off the stage.
We've been to the moon
six times with humans,
we have three robotic
sample return missions sent
by the Soviets, all in a line here.
And several other landers
all across the near side.
But again, there's an entire half
of the moon that remains unexplored.
Just as a bit of a preview,
there's a feature I'm going
to be talking about
a little later on.
The tycho crater here.
This is a very bright feature
that's visible to the naked eye
when the moon is full, but I do that
as a bit of a preview to call back.
The LROC team has an amazing website
with clickable, searchable images.
I encourage you.
There's a lot of wonderful
time-syncs,
real news that you can explore
by seeing what's going
on with the camera.
It's amazing images that
the camera is returning.
Ok. So again as a bit of context
for what's going on in 1972,
and again because we're at
the Library of Congress,
I hold up the Apollo 17
preliminary science report.
Nice, light reading.
This was drafted sort of
in the immediate aftermath.
Each of the missions had a
preliminary science report.
But what that served as the first
digestion of what we learned.
It's really an impressive document
and I spend fafr too mich time
leafing through it because there's
so many wonderful nuggets.
Now this is a bit of inside
baseball information here.
I was not born in 1972, so
looking back at what was going
on really offers an insight
into what was happening
with science at the time.
And there's this quote that I pulled
from the preliminary science report
which sort of blew my mind.
In the past decade, there
have been two revolutions
in planetary science studies.
There has been a revolution
in new global tectonics,
describing the motions of
continents and the generation
and destruction of the sea floor.
That's right, I forgot--
1960's, this revolution.
The theory of plate tectonics was
deposited and shown to be feasible.
This is happening almost
contemporaneously
with the Apollo program.
With our return of samples.
And so the second half of this
quote, and it's investigations
of the origin, history,
and formation of the moon,
the Apollo program has led
to a-- and you can all read.
I'm just reading this because--
providing the first deep
understanding of a planet other
than the Earth through the
development of new techniques
of exploration, investigation,
and analysis.
And through the integration
of scientific knowledge,
gained an interdisciplinary fields.
And another really
important side effect benefit
from Apollo is the advancement
in analytical techniques
and also bringing in of
researchers into studying samples.
Now I'm very fortunate to work
with a number of people who are
on the front lines
studying Apollo samples.
And they're still active today.
Fewer and fewer every year.
Every year at our conferences,
the old timer group is
getting a little bit smaller.
Still as vocal as ever,
but smaller and smaller.
But it was this period in time
where there was an advancement
of scientific analysis
techniques of the instrumentation,
partially because of the samples
coming back that we knew we needed
to study these samples to really
make the scientific investment
in Apollo worthwhile.
So all of this revolution
[inaudible] the Earth is being
accompanied by our understanding of
the moon and our sort of advancement
in exploration through the
rest of the solar system.
Earlier, I mentioned that
Apollo 17 was the final mission.
It was the last of what
we call the J missions.
Heavy-duty scientific experiment
laden missions with the rovers.
It had ten surface experiments
to take on the lunar surface.
Ten were conducted in lunar orbit.
This is a plot, again, from
the preliminary science report
of basically the distance the Apollo
astronauts traversed while they were
on the surface.
Apollo 11 didn't leave the
infield of the baseball diamond.
They just got out and walked
around the immediate
vicinity of the lander.
By the time Apollo 15, 16, and
17 came along with the rovers,
they were driving over 20
kilometers across the lunar surface.
The massive of experiments that
were brought to the surface and left
on the surface was increasing.
The time outside of the lunar
module was now well over one day,
24 hours spent outside the
surface of the lunar module.
And of course, then the weight o the
samples brought back was increasing
dramatically across that time.
Has anybody, how many people have
ever been to the British Museum
or have seen the Rosetta Stone?
Ok, the Rosetta Stone
is this iconic figure
in our understanding
of Ancient Egypt.
And if you ever go
see the Rosetta Stone,
it's this beautiful [inaudible] It's
a beautiful rock with all of the--
etchings and words
on it are nice too.
But the rock itself is beautiful.
The combined mass of
the samples brought back
by Apollo is almost exactly
to the kilogram half the
mass of the Rosetta Stone.
Now, the mass of the
Rosetta Stone doesn't matter.
It's what's written on that
one side that matters most.
I think there's this
misinterpretation that,
oh there's truckloads of rocks
that came back from the moon.
No, these are precious samples
and I've said this before:
putting those samples
into the context
of where they were collected,
what they tell us about not only
that spot on the moon, that region,
but then by association that we have
with the data from orbit, the rest
of the moon is really,
really important.
Now there's one other experiment,
and I put in quotes experiment,
that was brought to the
surface on Apollo 17.
And as I was putting this talk
together I got maybe a little
carried away with this thought,
but there was one experiment
that was the culmination
of decades of development.
And particularly the Mercury,
Gemini, and Apollo programs.
And that experiment was in
the form of Dr. jack Schmidt.
Harrison Schmidt.
He was the first and thus
far only geologist to walk
on the surface of the moon.
He was the last one to get
out of the lunar module,
the twelfth to walk on the surface.
He was in the first group of
scientist astronauts selected
by NASA in the mid 1960's,
and he had participated,
once he was selected, he had
participated in the training
for prior missions and helped
in the analysis of samples
that were brought back, as well as
the other surface investigations.
So he was intimately aware of
what the prior missions had done,
their results, and what I
want to at least leave you
with here is the importance
of having, hopefully we'll be
at a position in the not-too-distant
future we'll have astronauts going
to the surfaces of objects.
Having a geologist,
a trained geologist,
part of that process
is very important.
I know Jim has worked in the field
with several astronaut candidates,
has participated in some
events working with astronauts.
The ideas of getting trained
scientists on the surfaces
of planets is very important.
Because what they can do is not
only call upon their decades
of experience in the field, but also
kind of put together a synthesis
of what the results of
that investigation are.
We benefitted not only by
having Jack on the surface
of the moon then, but also now
44 years later working with him
to reanalyze what he did
on the surface of the moon
on those three days in 1972.
And so one of the benefits
that I feel is happened strongly
today is not only he gets the right
samples but he's helped
us tell that story.
Again, take those stories each rock
tells us and weave a narrative.
A history behind those rocks.
So let's go back to why
Apollo 17 was sent to the moon
and what its objectives were.
Now Apollo 17 was being planned
in the early part of 1972.
This was hot on the heels of
Apollo 15 but before Apollo 16,
and there were five
objectives laid out.
This is defined by an August panel
of leaders saying that they wanted
to sample ancient lunar crust.
As far from the Apollo 15
landing site as possible.
When I showed you that map of Apollo
landing sites, they all cluster
in a region roughly
around the equator,
but they are also very
close to one large feature.
The imbrium basin.
They wanted to get a landing site
as far from the imbrium basin
as safely possible so that
they could gather the diversity
of the lunar surface.
They wanted to sample what they
thought were young volcanic rocks.
Most of the volcanic rocks that we
got back from the moon are the order
of three to four billion years old.
And they wanted to try to get
rocks that were younger than that.
Volcanic rocks that
were younger than that.
They wanted to get improved coverage
by the orbiting command module.
The command module orbited sort
of in a roughly hula hoop band
around the surface of
the moon that passed
over each of the landing sites.
They wanted to get coverage that
improved upon the prior missions.
They wanted to be able to deploy
geophysical elements on the surface,
but also in an area that
had some surface layers.
They're looking for a
volcanically covered region
to measure the thickness
of those volcanic layers.
And then also deploy the experiments
that would then subsequently be left
on the surface of the moon
after the mission concluded.
So the Apollo 17 landing site, and
there's my first typo of the day,
was selected on-- this
is not an Irish spelling.
This was on February 11th, 1972.
So just keep in mind,
so they have had,
at this point they had essentially
one year or just under a year,
ten months to plan the investigation
at the Taurus-Littrow
Valley for Apollo 17.
So with these five goals and the
identification of a landing site,
specific traverses were identified
to address those five topics.
And so using images that came
back from the Apollo 15 mission,
and these prior missions
all shouted for each other.
They were all imaging potential
landing sites for future missions.
Five different units,
five different areas
within the Taurus-Littrow
Valley here,
five different units
were identified.
It may be a little hard
to see in the screen here,
but there is this light
debris material,
this light colored unit called
the light mantel deposit
that they wanted to sample.
There's the dark mantel deposit
and this is a larger unit
where the floor of the valley,
this dark floor of the valley,
appeared to have some
kind of covering.
The craters that you see
on the surface all appear
to be somewhat degraded.
You ever picture your lawn or
your front yard or some large area
on a snowy day everything, your
wall, gets a little bit subdued.
So there was this hypothesis that
there was some covering material,
something covering the
floor of the valley here
that they wanted to sample.
They wanted to sample whatever
was below that, the subfloor.
They also wanted to get
material from this unit here.
This is called the sculptured hills.
This has a slightly
different texture.
To use a very technical term,
lumpy, compared to these mountains
to the North and South of the
valley that appear to be--
to use another technical
term-- mountain like.
There are these little knobs
in the sculptured hills
where the [inaudible] appear
to be one large, coherent unit.
So with the identification of
these five different units,
traverses were identified based
on the optimal landing site
in the middle of the valley
where the astronauts could drive
around the valley to sample
these different materials.
Just as a point of comparison, talk
about the Taurus-Littrow Valley
and a little bit of scale, this
is the Grand Canyon on the Earth.
This is, again, using that
amazing tool Google Earth,
and this is a transect
through the Grand Canyon.
So this is about 30
kilometers from end to end.
Covers about a kilometer and a
half, 1.8 kilometers of relief.
For comparison, this is
the Taurus-Littrow Valley,
same 3 thirty kilometers across.
This is two and a half, 2.3
kilometers of elevation change.
So this is another important
thing to consider here.
With the first Apollo
landing, Apollo 11,
they landed in what they thought was
the smoothest safest landing site,
as far from hazards as they could.
And of course when they
tried to land on Apollo 11,
they were headed right
for a boulder field.
And so Neil Armstrong had to
steer the lunar module away
from those boulders.
Just four years later,
they were able to land
in a valley deeper
than the Grand Canyon.
That's an incredible
advancement in a very short order,
going from finding the safest
landing site to landing in a valley
where you have towering
mountains on either side of you.
That was quite the accomplishment.
Ok, so let's now look after mission.
How did the-- let's
give the astronauts,
let's give the Apollo
17 crew an evaluation.
How did they do?
So, for those pre-flight objectives,
they were indeed able to go
and sample this light mantel
deposit, this debris flow.
And an interpretation
was made from--
an interpretation from the origin
of this debris flow was made
that material from
that tycho crater,
and I showed you that image earlier.
Tycho crater is located
over 1,000 kilometers away
from the Apollo 17 landing site.
That objected material shot
out of that crater, landed,
hit the top of the South [inaudible]
and triggered a landslide.
So the interpretation was that the
astronauts sampled this material
that was estimated to be
about 100 million years old,
was caused by the formation of
that crater, 1,000 kilometers away.
And so this is one of the
beauties of lunar science is
that you can have an event 1,000
kilometers away trigger a landslide
here, and we can go and
sample that landslide
and get the age of that crater.
So that's handy.
And as a reminder, geologists
are very interested in organiza--
if you ever come to my
office, you may not think
that geologists are
interested in organizing things,
but indeed we like putting events
into some sort of sequence.
And so getting the ages of
events is very important.
So an interpretation was made
that the samples collected
from this debris flow were triggered
by that impact 100
million years ago.
The second objective was
to sample the dark mantel,
and that proved to be difficult.
And again, in this
preliminary science report,
interpretation was made that that
origin of that dark mantel deposit,
the subdued texture of the
surface, remains one of the enigmas
of the Apollo 17 missions.
So we can't necessarily say
that that was addressed.
Now, they did however
sample much of the subfloor.
This volcanic fill that flowed
in and filled the valley.
They sampled that quite extensively.
The fourth objective of
sampling the sculptured hills,
now one of the last stations
on Apollo 17, station 8 here,
which the primary objective of which
was to sample the sculptured hills.
But at the time it
remained uncertain.
And no more is known about
the sculptured hills unit
than it is indeed different.
It looks different than the
[inaudible] to the North and South.
And so this remained an
open question of whether
or not any material from the
sculptured hills were ever sampled.
And lastly, the [inaudible] and
those were sampled very well.
And as I'll show in a moment,
several stations were along the base
of the [inaudible] Of course they
could not drive up the [inaudible]
but instead of having to go get
the rocks, the rocks came to them.
Several boulders were
observed to have rolled
down the hills well
before the mission.
These were boulders that were
seen in preflight images.
And so they drove to the
boulders knowing that they came
from somewhere up the mountain.
And so those were sampled
quite well.
So Now, this is the
Apollo 17 landing site.
The Taurus-Littrow Valley as
imaged by the camera on LRO.
Again, so this is an image
from 1972, here it is today.
Looks the same.
Again, those changes that
are occurring on the surface
of the moon are occurring at smaller
scales than what we can see even
in this particular image here.
Apollo 17 landing site is
marked very small right here.
Right in the middle, essentially,
of the valley, giving easy access
to these units that
they wanted to sample.
In addition to wanting
to put things in order,
geologists like naming things, so
these were all craters and features
that were named by the crew
to help in communications,
and then in yellow is the
traverses that they took.
Over 20 kilometers of traverses,
starting with the very first
traverse on day one, traverse two,
and finally, traverse three.
So let's sort of retrace their
steps a little bit and evaluate some
of the open questions that
they left that still remain--
well, remain unanswered until today.
But for a bit of context,
just to help drive everybody,
this is the traverse in the
context of D.C., so we're sitting
in a building right over here.
A colleague of mine, Brent Gary, who
works at Goddard and is a colleague
of Jim's back here, made
this really helpful map.
If you put the landing site right
on top of the Smithsonian Metro
which on a normal day
isn't that easy to get to,
but landing a lunar module
on it might be the best way.
They were able to cover quite a
bit of distance getting not only
on day one close to Nats Park
but not all the way there.
But day two going well
into Arlington,
and day three up into Northeast
D.C. Somewhere in here is a joke
about either the metro
or local traffic
but I'm not quite sure
how best to make that.
Fortunately, they didn't
have to contend with traffic.
But this does give you a sense.
That they were able with the rover
to cover quite a good
amount of distance.
So that landing site, so here's
the Smithsonian Metro Station,
this is an image from the camera
and all of these black streaks
on here are traces of their
boot prints or in some cases,
and if you get real close, and
normally I'd say [inaudible]
and take a look, you can
actually see two parallel lines.
Those are the tracks of the rover.
The wheel tracks still
there 44 years later.
The next slide is actually
going to be a series of images.
Pretty much every time the
spacecraft passes over any
of the Apollo landing sites,
we take an image of it.
And so what I'm going to show here
is a series of eighteen images.
We passed over the site
more than eighteen times,
but eighteen illuminated times--
showing basically the landing site
as a function of solar angle.
Basically time of day.
From morning to nighttime.
And it's going to loop and will
let me talk a little bit about some
of the things that we can see.
Good, it works.
Ok, so at center here is the
descent stage, the bottom half
of the lunar module sitting
on the surface today.
There's the shadows creeping along.
This black spot here is the
lunar rover which is parked
at the culmination of the EVA's
sitting on the surface there.
And the west is the [inaudible]
station, scientific experiments
that were set up and left
operating for about five years
until they were shut off in
September of 1977 prematurely.
So you can very accurately retrace
the steps the astronauts took.
There was an experiment that
was set up here as well,
so we can literally follow the
footsteps of the Apollo astronauts.
There's one other feature that moves
around here that you might follow.
I'll take the laser pointer
off, you'll see a spot moving,
a shadow moving across the surface.
Anybody want to venture a
guess at what that shadow is?
Jim, you can't answer that.
Ben, you can't either.
You know the answer.
Yes. So one of the great mysteries--
mystery in the sense
of what will we find,
and one of the great questions, is
will we see evidence of the flags
at the Apollo landing sites?
We know that the Apollo 11 flag was
knocked over when they lifted off.
There's footage of that from the
lunar module as they lifted off,
the flag got knocked over.
12's flag never deployed properly.
There's a rod that hangs
it out so it stands
out at attention beautifully.
But there was a question of whether
or not we would see anything.
Now if you ask me, before the
mission I would have said no.
there's no chance that
the flags are still there.
This flag is probably as
well if not better designed
than the flags that
are brought there.
They were off the shelf, not quite
go down to the local hardware store
but essentially had an
objective of lasting three days
on the moon and that was it.
Well, we get these pictures
back and there's only one thing
that can cast a shadow like that
and some of the images taken
of other landing sites, you can see.
I'm sure the flag has been bleached.
You leave a colored shirt
out in the sun too long
over the summer it
will bleach white.
I'm sure that any color that were
on the flags were bleached away
but nope, they flags
are still standing.
Ok, yeah that's a good question.
So this is about 100
meters right here.
So a football field.
This lunar module, and I
would encourage everyone to go
over to the Smithsonian to
see an actual lunar module.
Well not one that flew, of
course, but a lunar module.
So this covers about, all
told, about 400 meters across.
This flag was put about
twenty meters
to the north of the lunar module.
They learned from Apollo 11
that having it too close meant
that it got blown over when they
launched and so no one wanted
to knock over the American
flag a second time
on the surface of the moon.
So if nothing else,
that was kind of cool.
As a quick aside, there's a
letter in the NASA archives
at NASA headquarters of someone
violently complaining as a lot
of people tend to do, of
the waste of sending flags
and why would we spend
the extra money,
and some very dutiful NASA civil
servant wrote back saying well,
here's a copy of the
receipt for those flags.
It was like five bucks.
It was a lot of talk
about investment
and so this is not a huge
expenditure of resources
to get flags to the moon.
Ok. This is a fly through
that the camera team produced
to just highlight some
more of the hardware.
I think, ok so here's the
descent stage of Challenger.
You can still see the footpaths.
This is where the ladder
where the astronauts exited
and entered the spacecraft.
There's your flag still
standing on the surface.
The experiment packages that was
called the [inaudible] deployed
on the surface.
There was over ten experiments
that were brought to the surface
that were designed to last upwards
of twenty years but we're going
to shut off after five years.
Over to the east of the landing site
is the surface electrical properties
experiment and then to the
South is the lunar rover.
There is a documentary put together
by CNN called the last steps
that should be aired
sometime this week.
It's available online if
you Google The Last Steps.
But some of the footage that's
impressive, especially of the ascent
when the lunar module took off.
Let me go back one moment.
Camera mounted on the lunar rover
actually shows the astronauts taking
off from the surface and
then pans back around.
And you can see the orientation
of the flag as it was then
and you know, that
was the last time.
December 1972, that
humans ever touched space.
And it really hasn't
changed at all since then.
Ok, so now I'm going
to revisit in the time
that I have left three questios that
we've been able to address using LRO
and modern data in a peper
that-- and this is #HumbleBrag.
Jack Schmidt was interested in
looking at what data we have
for Apollo 17 and so he put
together with the help of myself
and several other people, a
paper not quite as thick as this.
It feels like it's
that thick, though.
A really deep investigation
into the Apollo 17 landing site
with modern data.
And so we're going to
address these three questions.
What is the origin of
that light mantel deposit?
Where was this sample?
Sample 70019.
Where was that collected?
And there's an interesting
backstory to that.
And was sculptured hills material
sampled during the mission?
So let's talk about the
light mantel deposit.
So this is a very quickly sped up
video produced that Ben has posted
to his website, apollo17.org, that
allows us to follow the astronauts
as they begin traverse two.
EVA two. Starting at the lunar
module and driving all the way
down to the South maseef.
This is easily about five kilometers
of driving that they had to do
to get there, over
quite a long time.
Stopping several times not for rest
breaks, but to sample the surface.
As they got to the base
of the south maseef here,
they actually had to
drive up this ridge.
This is a tectonic feature called
a wrinkle ridge where two parts
of the lunar crusts essentially
collided and one went on top
of the floor here,
creating this ridge.
So this second traverse, this
EVA two, was designed partially
to collect material of
this light mantel deposit.
As I said before, the assumption
was that the light mantel deposit
in Apollo 17 is here,
came from tycho crater.
And you can see the
beautiful streaks
of material coming
out of tycho crater.
The thought was that some
material was ejected,
impacted the south maseef
and caused this avalanche.
So this is an image from
the LRO camera taken
when the sun is very high in the
sky as you saw in that animation
of the Apollo 17 landing site that
depending on what angle the sun is
with the sky, you can
make out different things.
When the sun is low in the
ground, you can see boulders,
craters, surfaces, very well.
When the sun is high in the sky,
seeing those features
becomes very difficult
but you can see differences
in color very clearly.
The bright tracks, the bright
lander, the dark rocks beneath.
Here is this debris flow.
And something that came out
to us in this investigation is
that it appears that there's
a darker debris flow here
and a lighter debris flow here.
Now it's very possible that this
lighter debris flow covers this
darker unit here, but it's
apparent to use that instead
of one massive landslide
coming off the South maseef,
it appears that there are two.
The darker one in the subsequent
unit, this lighter one here.
And so what this tells us is
that perhaps this debris flow
represents multiple events
and not one single triggering
event such as the placement
of ejector from tycho crater.
Just as a slightly different
perspective, this is again one
of the out the window views.
These oblique's.
Again, taken from somewhat high
sun so you can see the differences
in the original image, anyway,
you can see the differences
of the younger flow
and this older flow.
Here's their landing site here.
And so what this potentially tells
us, and this is at high sun here
and so that becomes very apparent,
or at least becomes apparent
that there are these
two debris flows,
is that perhaps there's multiple
events triggering these avalanches
on the lunar surface.
So that sort of gave
us one of those moments
when we think what have we done?
Are we wrong?
What could cause these avalanches.
I pointed out moments ago that there
are indeed those tectonic features,
those scarps.
This is this data from
our radar instrument.
And again, the radar instrument lets
us look slightly below the surface.
Deeper into the surface.
Here is that fault, that scarp,
it's called the Lee-Lincoln scarp.
The valley here is seven kilometers
wide and you can barely make
out here the outline of at
least the younger debris flow.
But it looks like there may
actually be a second fault
that goes along near the
older landslide as well.
So our conclusion, at least at this
point, and it's explained much more
in the paper, is that instead
of having to rely on objector
from a crater 1,000 kilometers
away, these landslides
that were sampled very well
by the Apollo 17 mission may
actually even be triggered
by a much more localized event.
Indeed, moonquakes forming
these tectonic features.
And so that's sort of a
big shift in understanding.
We've used that age of tycho
for samples now for 44-45 years.
Turns out that tycho is probably
still very young but we may have
to remove tycho from one of
those features on the moon
that we know it's precise age.
Something that we do know
precisely well is now the origin
of this sample.
Sample 70019.
This is sampled by Jack
near the lunar module
at the culmination
of his second EVA.
Let me pull the curtain
back a little bit.
I was making this slide
and I was thinking oh,
how am I going to explain
this sample?
I could get into some
of the technical details
but I don't have to.
I'm going to let Jack explain
a little bit about what he did.
And so--
>> Hey Bob?
>> Go ahead.
>> I cheated on you.
>> I was sure you would.
What'd you do?
>> I just sampled a glass
from the bottom of a crater.
I documented it by shooting the
limb across the crater [inaudible]
and it's eleven feet and in
that prospect it's seven.
And then I sampled it.
>> Ok.
>> It's very fragile.
That's right.
Very fragile and I double back and I
don't know if we can keep it or not.
We need to think about
how to preserve it.
>> Ok.
>> Noah Petro: So this
is from Apollo17.org.
Again, it's you'll spend the
rest of your day at this website.
I've had, well that's Jack
describing sampling this rock
from the floor of this crater.
Now because of his
experience in prior missions,
he knew that young craters
would have glass covered floors.
And his thought was that if we
could sample a rock from the floor
of this crater, one of these
craters that's very young
that hasn't been disturbed,
we may be able
to measure the magnetic field
of the moon in those samples
because theoretically, those
fragments, those rocks on the floor
of the crater haven't
been disturbed,
haven't moved since
the crater formed.
So if you know exactly the
orientation of the sample
as it was the moment
the crater formed
and then a million years later
when he came along and sampled it
and put it in the lab, he put it
exactly in the same orientation,
you could measure any
paleo old magnetic field.
So he went through some
painstaking efforts not only
to find the right crater,
to sample it,
and bring it back and preserve it.
And he did that.
It was brought back, analyzed,
but essentially largely forgotten.
He went off on a world tour, he
went back and analyzed the samples,
but never really revisited
the sample and never did
that really detailed documentation
of trying to reposition exactly
where that sample came from.
So one of the coauthors
of this paper took it
upon himself to do that.
Now this is that first
image he describes taking
where he knows he has the
lunar module precisely located
in the image, the sample
came from right here.
And then using basically some very
simple reconstruction techniques we
can identify features in the image.
And this is a blow up
of this image here.
It's hard to see, but basically
it's a before and after
that lets us show exactly
where that sample came form
in the floor of this crater.
Now tying these features, we've
got the lunar module, these craters
and boulders sitting on the surface.
There's the tracks of the
rover in the image there.
This is the LROC image.
There's the lunar module.
There's feature A, B, C, and
D. We can precisely locate,
just using trigonometry
that I thought
in high school I'd never need to use
again, and find exactly where he was
on the surface when he
sampled that crater and exactly
which crater that came from.
It was never determined exactly,
there's a lot of craters.
But we were able to say exactly
where that sample came from
and now a series of at least
proposals are under way to try
and get the money to be
able to analyze that sample
in the way that Jack saw fit.
It's very elegant, very simple,
but essentially allows
us to precisely know.
And actually an important thing
I mentioned, the topography
of the moon being as
well understood as it is:
we now know where features
are on the lunar surface.
Especially around the lunar
modules, within centimeters.
Further away from the lunar
modules, a few meters.
But we have a precise, genetic grid.
We know where features are on
the lunar surface to a degree
that we've really never known
for any planetary body
apart from the Earth before.
And the last point I wanted to make
is about these sculptured hills.
This is, again, out of
an airplane window view.
Here is the North and south maseefs,
here's that Lee-Lincoln scarp,
the landslide, there's
where they landed.
And this is the sculptured hills.
And perhaps you can start bleeding
when you see this knobby texture
versus this more coherent texture,
and you can pair the sculptured
hills to the South maseef.
And so the third and final
EVA went to the North and East
up along the base of
the North maseef,
two stations where large boulders
were identified and finally
to the bottom of the sculptured
hills to sample that material
at station eight and then
finally make their way back
to the lunar module.
Jack, my coauthor for the talk,
described a little bit
about what they did.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: So there's Jack who's
scampered, almost the right word,
up 30 meters uphill, not easy, to
get this one rock of the whole area
that he sees that's unusual.
And what you hear him do
is just the best example
of field geology on the moon.
He's telling Gene, all these
rocks around here are the same.
Get one of these things.
Not going to worry about it,
but that rock up the hill
there, that's what I want.
>> A minute to make up some
of this time we've spent
at station 6 and 7--
>> Noah Petro: Oh come on.
Come on. Mute.
Ha ha. Awesome field geology,
this field site happens
to be on the moon.
He's telling Gene, get
one of these samples.
I'm going to go up and get that one.
That's unusual, that doesn't
look like these other things.
That's what we want to get.
He goes up, he documents it, images
it, then he starts trying to kick it
to roll it downhill and
it goes down a little bit.
Because he knew that that
was the unusual sample
and potentially would be
from the sculptured hills.
But as I showed in that
documentation and really
for decades, it was never thought
we were able to get materials
from the sculptured hills.
That rock that Jack is
doing an excellent job
of documenting, was unusual.
It was unlike other sample--
let me go forward one.
It was unlike-- I could
play that video.
It's just so awesome.
Unlike other samples, there was
no visible [inaudible] In fact
if I had let Jack talk more which
I probably should have done,
he says there's no boulder.
We don't know where it came from.
That boulder was unlike any
of the other boulders they
samples over at station 6 or 7.
This is an LROC view
of these boulders.
Here's the close up view.
They went here and sampled this
and you can see the little trail
of the boulder which
goes up the mountain.
Station seven boulder.
They actually didn't see the
boulder trail when they were
on the surface here, only with these
images are we able to see oh yes,
station seven boulder came
from further up the hill.
So that's one other area where
the new data has really helped
in the analysis.
But the boulder from
station eight had no context.
And I said before, context is king.
But we pulled in another data set.
A compositional data set that came
from a mission just before LRO.
An Indian mission that
had on it an instrument
that I was fortunate
enough to work on.
The Moon Minerology Mapper.
And this psychedelic
on the right-hand side here
is basically a color map--
a compositional map.
And colors indicate variations
in composition, specifically
minerology.
And in the North massif which
is here, basically we see apart
from a few examples, it's largely
[inaudible] which is the kind
of average composition of the
lunar surface, of the lunar crust.
The sculptured hills is a
much more polka dot pattern
of different colors, suggesting
that it's much more compositionally
diverse and indeed, the composition
of that boulder that was
sampled at station eight,
matches almost identically the
composition that we can infer
of the uphill portion
of that mountain.
So that tells us that indeed, it
did sample sculptured hills material
and has led to a whole
different understanding
of what this material represents.
Our current hypothesis is that,
remember I mentioned earlier
that they wanted to go as far from
the embrium basin as possible?
It turns out that there's a chance
that this material is actually
objected from that large basin.
Maybe we didn't get ejecta from
tycho but we may have gotten ejecta
from the embrium basin in the
form of the sculptured hills.
And this material will be very
deep material ejected by that basin
over about a thousand kilometers
from the Apollo 17 landing site
and brought here about
3.8 billion years ago.
So it turns out that, again,
some of this new data tells
us as much as they thought.
Maybe they weren't able to
sample the sculptured hills.
By golly, they did.
And again, you saw that example of
Jack doing what geologists do best
which is observe, classify very
quickly, and find the outlier.
The geologist, you always want
to hang out with the geologist.
They're going to find the best
restaurant that nobody goes to
or the best bar that nobody goes
to because there's one thing
that geologists don't like
to do is wait in line.
So new light on the
Taurus-Littrow Valley
and the Apollo 17 landing site.
One, it appears that tycho may
not have caused that avalanche.
That we may actually not have
an accurately aged the tycho
crater event.
We have located the exact
source and orientation
of this precious sample, 70019.
And that indeed the sculptured
hills were sampled at station eight
in the form of that
boulder which suggests
that the sculptured hills have a
very complex and convoluted origin
that involved a basin
1,000 kilometers away.
Ok, so Apollo 17.
Still crazy after all these years.
I'm going to elave you
with just a few thoughts.
We have a lot left to
learn about the moon.
We have not, in any
way, closed the book
on our understanding of the moon.
We have many future missions
that we'd like to explore.
I'm involved with a group that's
proposing or will propose a mission
to sample from the
far side of the moon.
We have a successful current
mission at the moon that's healthy
and happy, and of course we have
the wealth of past missions: robotic
and human, that we're
still learning from.
Apollo has left an incredible legacy
that we are still unraveling
and understanding.
As much as these are events that
happened 44 and more years ago,
they're still as relevant
today and still as important
to our understanding of the moon.
And this is perhaps masybe
the least important statement
but maybe also the most important
statement that I'll make today,
is the solar system is amazing.
All of the planets tell us
something about how planets
in our solar system
and indeed in all
of the other solar
systems in the galaxy work.
And the moon is one of
our best opportunities
to understand the processes that
shape all these solid bodies.
With that, I'll thank you for
your time and your attention.
Two minutes over.
Not bad for me.
And thank you for your time today.
[applause]
>> Michelle Cadoree Bradley:
Please, if you'd like to start
with any questions and we
see a number of hands raised.
So why don't we go
from bottom to top.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: So Apollo, so yes,
the question was Apollo's 18, 19,
and 20 were originally missions
that were going to happen.
Actually Jack Schmidt was going
to be the lunar module pilot
on Apollo 18 and got bumped up
to 17 when 18 was cancelled.
And so the question, if I hear
you correctly, is the equipment
that was built for those three
missions still usable-- oh.
>> Not equipment.
Whatever the mission you're looking
for geologically on the moon,
are those missions that cannot
be fulfilled in the 18, 19,
going to replicated in some fashion
with what you're doing now or?
>> Noah Petro: Ok, yes,.
So basically the landing sites or
the objectives of those missions,
are those still viable today?
Yeah, absolutely.
Apollo, and those missions were
cancelled early enough along
that they didn't get into
the incredibly detailed ok,
we're going to land here and sample
these places and there were a number
of possible landing sites that
were identified for those missions.
I'd say the story has almost gotten
more complicated because now we know
that there are many more
places we'd want to go.
But certainly those landing sites
which would've been a Copernicus
crater, there are several lava
or magnetic features or volcanic
features that were identified.
There are amongst many
possible future landing sites.
The geologists are
also sometimes greedy.
We don't want to just go back--
I mean, if we could go back to
one spot that would be great.
But you know, one place isn't
going to answer all the questions.
So, but certainly the work
that was done then is relevant.
It's actually one of the things in
my limited amount of time in working
for NASA and Jim might share this
thought, it NASA is really good
at a lot of things but one
of them is making reports.
And so every decade or so
there is another report.
And this is not intended
to criticize anybody,
it's important to revisit it.
But there are a number of ok, here
are the five most important things
that we can do in the next ten years
and every ten years
we brush that off.
But those landing sites would still
be amongst many high priority spots.
>> You said that the experiments
were cancelled after five years.
Why?
>> Noah Petro: That's, ok.
Money, basically.
The [inaudible] program has
active experiments going
on from the Apollo.
Ultimately, each of the
missions left something behind
but the long lived ones were at
Apollo's 12, 14, 15, 16, and 17.
And those were terminated
on September 30th, 1977.
Now for those of you in the civil
service or work for the government,
September 30th is the
end of the fiscal year.
And they were turned off because it
was costing a million dollars a year
to operate those experiments.
There was also a concern at the
Johnson Space Center, there's a room
that was used to basically,
you know,
the 1977 equivalent
of a server farm.
Basically the station where the
room, maybe as large as this room,
that was used to get the data,
process it, and then archive it,
was valuable real estate at JSC.
And they were getting ready for
the deorbit of Skylab which was one
of the later Apollo missions,
upper stage of the Saturn five
that was used as our
first space station.
Again, the engineering model,
the training model is
there at the space museum.
And so that room, the folks that
were concerned about bringing Skylab
down safely, they wanted
space to be able to do that.
And so that was another
argument that was used
to terminate [inaudible] was
that they needed the room.
They wanted that room.
So it's ultimately those
two things that conspired
against the right word
while I said it.
So that basically acted to terminate
the [inaudible] program prematurely.
Some of the equipment was failing
but there was still very
important seismic date,
there was still information
to be learned.
But a million dollars a year was
deemed needed to go elsewhere.
So it was terminated.
Apollo 17's operated again for that
five years but you had Apollo 12
that had been running since 1969
so in some cases it was seven
or more years of almost continuous
data coming down from the moon.
There was a question on the, yep.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: Yeah I can
go back to-- let me see.
Yeah, I mean this was
as if you were there.
It's good.
For some people I don't want to
strap to the side of a rocket.
Nobody in this room.
This is not sped up, certainly
I didn't do any monkeying
around with this.
It goes very fast.
And remember, this is
going, well the Saturn Five
when it cleared the tower
three or four seconds
after launch was going
60 miles an hour.
That's pretty slow when
you think about it.
I can go-- I've got CRV and I can go
faster than that in three seconds.
Not that I ever would though.
But you know, this is a lighter
rocket and it clears the cloud deck,
it was not a very cloudy
day that day
but it was cloudy enough,
within a few seconds.
But it takes-- actually, if you
go back and watch the launch
of New Horizons to Pluto,
I mean that cleared the
moon in a couple hours.
Six hours or less.
Because that thing
had to get going fast.
We only had to get to the moon so
we didn't have to go that fast.
But launching rockets is awesome.
We'll go back and then come back.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: Ok.
Yeah, so that's a great question.
And actually, the origin and age
of the moon is really
important because,
that's again the big question.
We still argue about that.
But indeed, the samples, even from
the very first mission Apollo 11,
showed us that the
moon was very old.
And under, most likely underwent
a global melting event early
in its history.
And so early on, a model was
developed that hypothesized
that about four and a half billion
years ago, an object about the size
of Mars struck the Earth and
sent into orbit around the moon,
basically for lack of a more
technical term, a bunch of debris.
But ejecta from the Earth
that coalesced, reheated,
and melted to form the
lunar crust and mantel.
And so samples from subsequent
missions show that the crust
of the moon is about
4.4 billion years old
and so a more detailed analysis
has gone back and showed when some
of that would have
actually coalesced.
But on the Earth, there are some
very few places, Northern Canada,
Central Australia, where you
can get rocks that are upwards
of 3.8 billion years old.
But those are few and far between.
Whereas the crust of the moon
has these rocks pretty much,
I won't say everywhere, but
widespread rocks that are 4.3
or older billion years old.
And there's still arguments
about the age of the moon.
We know that it's likely older than
4.4 billon years, but there's a lot
of that early history
in the solar system
that we don't very well understand.
But the record for those
rocks is sitting on the moon
and likely not sitting
here on the Earth.
So we just went through staging,
that was the bright flash there.
And in a moment, you'll see
the space crust separation
if you're worried about it.
Fortunately we know LRO survives,
so anything you see here
couldn't have been too bad.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: Yeah, so the
question is about some recent work
and it's very good to see a lot of
effort going back into reanalyzing
and asking these questions.
It's not a closed question
of the early dynamics
of where the moon came from.
And really, the more we
learn about the moon--
that the moon has water in it,
that it's not completely dried out,
punches some holes into the
theory of this large impact early
on because one of the ideas was
this early impact will devolatilize
whatever came to form
the moon very quickly.
Well we know the moon has volatiles
in it so I'd say it's still open
to debate and question
and I would say again,
perhaps a little self-serving
that more analysis
of these Apollo samples,
there are some Apollo samples
that have never been analyzed.
There's some samples that
haven't been analyzed in 45 years.
So I think we have a lot left
to learn from those samples
and looking towards what that tells
us about day one from the moon.
Moving down the line.
Yep.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: Well,
that's a great question
because I'm going to
speak for myself.
It's all I know.
I certainly feel like I missed out
on that opportunity to participate
for something like that and
hopefully, I'm not that old
but I know there's an end to my
career somewhere and hopefully
between here and there there's
something that I could contribute.
I think when we are ready to go
back to the moon as a species,
we can do so safely with
the data that we have here.
So yeah, I feel like I
missed out but there's a lot
of great things that
are going on here.
You know, we lost our way, we
got-- there was a war going on.
I wasn't there.
And looking at and talking to
folks, there was a certain sense of,
even Apollo 12 wasn't
as popular as Apollo 11.
The second time humans go
to the moon wasn't like--
by Apollo 13 people were
barely paying attention.
I think that tells u more
about how we have to.
I mean, we've learned a lot in
the last year about how our,
and when I say our I mean
the U.S., the attention span
and the interest of the country.
So whenever we are ready
to do something bibg,
and going to the moon was big.
Billions and billions of
dollars spent to do it.
Society, leadership has to
be on board to continue it.
We talked about turning
off [inaudible]
after five years or prematurely.
We have to be on board
with big investments.
And the investment that was
made in Apollo has told us
about the origin of the moon.
Again indeed, events are happening
four and a half billion years ago.
These are things that
can't be solved
for the price of this cup of coffee.
Even if it is from Starbucks.
You can't do it.
>> Michelle Cadoree Bradley: We
have time for one more question.
>> Noah Petro: Ok.
There's a question
in the front here.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
>> Noah Petro: Sure.
So this is radiation doses.
So the question is, what do we
know would happen and the causes
and events of a solar flare.
As I mentioned, one
of the instruments
on LRO is this radiation detector.
Unfortunately, the moon, the sun
has been fairly quiet the time
that we've been at the moon with
LRO for the last seven years,
so we haven't had one of these
large solar flares occur.
But we know that if not lethal,
a harmful does of radiation.
Now where would they go?
If we're on the moon for a long
period of time we we want to be able
to get the astronauts to sagety.
Now whether or not that shelter
is in their habitat that's covered
in some thickness of [inaudible]
that would protect them,
shield them, one of the
surprising discoveries
and I don't have an image of it.
So I'll just put a picture of
Mt. Marilyn up for a moment.
Is that there are places that
we've seen that are pits.
They're collapsed lava tubes.
We don't know if the pit is the size
of the hole or a little big larger,
or if there's an extensive
lava tube system.
We've seen these scattered
across the lunar surface.
Mostly in areas of volcanism.
Those could be good habitats,
because now of course you have
to get into it so you have to go
down into a pit that's
30, 40, 50 meters deep.
That's not easy.
You saw the astronauts
running around, climbing up
and down a rope ladder that's
going to be next to impossible
for an astronaut on the surface but
there may be some natural shelters
that we found on the moon that
would prove to be potential
if they're extensive enough
to be shelters for astronauts.
The other possibility, though,
is just designing a habitat
that has enough shielding.
Or again, if you can take the
loose material on the surface
and cover that, that could
provide enough protection.
Humans have remained in lower-Earth
orbit since 1972, and when you're
in lower-Earth orbit
you're in protection
of the Earth's magnetic field.
So if we want to go on to Mars,
this is going to be a major issue
for any long duration
deep space exploration,
will be radiation hazards.
But instruments like crater
and instruments that are
on Mars right now measuring
radiation,
we at least know the expected doses.
This provides some
arguments of whether
or not this means you should send
people who are young and can agree
that if this is going to
happen this is going to happen,
or if you send older people.
No offense.
Who don't have to worry about
having kids or anything like that.
Everybody's got their
own vested interests.
But it's definitely going to be one
of the major, although achievable,
but a major hurdle for long
duration deep space exploration.
>> Michelle Cadoree Bradley:
Dr. Petro, thank you very much,
we have so enjoyed
this presentation.
If you have questions,
perhaps you can come outwards
and down and talk with Dr. Petro.
>> Noah Petro: Absolutely.
[applause]
>> Noah Petro: Thank you very much!
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.